it stands to reason that if this is the
case right I'll just make it made this
is a statement it's the reverse of this
derivative is new integral saving here
if I see a fraction the derivatives on
the top of the function of the bottom
the denominator then I can take that we
can take that and this must have come
from a log function namely log of the
denominator okay I'm going to pause for
a second in a sense this is all you need
like exercise 12 B is now laid open to
you you just just go for it ok however
there's actually something dangerous
here that I haven't bothered pointing
out which you kind of don't need to know
as in to unit extension one students as
extensions to students you'll be
expected to know but what about to show
you is completely true unit in three I
just no reason why you can't notes I
want to show it to you some of you may
see some textbooks or you may have even
encountered at other times before this
class rather than log X they write log
of the absolute value of x okay and the
Navy after [ __ ] and then in the same
way here they say it's not just log of
that function of the denominator it's a
lot of the absolute value of that
phenomena of that function okay now
there are two or three ways you can
explain like why one of these absolute
values appear okay the first way is
actually not an explosion or it's just
to say cause you have to like it's magic
because because math okay that's just
the rule just deal with it okay that's
not an explanation clearly okay there's
one thing which is a bit better than
that we should say when you're taking
law of this is basie right you can't
just put any number you like in here
right log base E the only numbers you
can put in here are positive numbers
right you can never grow and get
negative you can get really really big
if you go backwards in time you can get
really really useful but you can never
go negative so you can't put negative
nuts in there so some people reason
since you can't put neighbors in there
yes slap absolute value sense now this
is see exactly the same as we
areas and it's like yeah just put out to
value science cuz because right it's
still not an explanation like who says I
should be able to assume that that's
going to be positive sometimes I can't
this function might be some weird thing
that sometimes positive sometimes
negative that's not the real explanation
here's the way the real explanation
works look carefully at this statement
do you agree that it is true you're
happy with that do you remember how we
prove that it's wrong it's not true at
all right well not sure at all it's not
true for all values of x it's only true
for what we just said right the log
function only exists for x is greater
than zero right where is whatever X it
exists for everywhere except for x
equals zero like it has very way over
exercises 0 so this statement is only
true for X positive therefore this which
is what i wrote down originally is also
only true for x positive okay so it's
kind of like all right now i have half
the picture how do i get the other heart
how do i understand what is happening on
this integral the answer is just like we
always do I come back to differentiation
this is not obvious stay with me you
need to drop this down if i
differentiate and i'm going to use this
second thing to chamberlain quite
differentiate is humanly what we're
going to get on the right hand side it's
not going to work
I know it's not going to regular got
there just why I'm using the calculator
this is chain rule so I should get F
dash oh yeah what's the F dash what's
that hold on i'm clearly different
function this do you agree they're
completely done function to this but
somehow by going through this process i
get the same thing and that actually
makes a lot of sense because when you
have a look at very quickly when you
have a look at the way the log function
appears autograph right his logins right
here is the part of the hyperbola
whatever x it tells me the dreary over
here at matches doesn't it super steep
at this point and then it gets shallower
and shallower and shallower that agrees
with what we our intuition tells us what
does this tell us what does longer minus
x look like how would you describe it
where's it gone has it not flipped over
to this side it's come over this side so
this is what model negative x looks like
what does 1 over X the hyperbola what it
look like over there and it answers it's
in the office of quadrant right which
true enough still matches like look at
over here the gradient of the log
function of here is very very shallow
right and decreasing and decreasing and
it's really steep decrease it makes
sense that we get the same derivative
for two completely different functions
ok so now i can make an integration save
it from this i can say if i integrate 1
over X Y X right I'm still going to get
a log function but i might get this
function awesome not that one in a
different domain right ok now look
carefully let me put some beef circles
on it look at this line and look at this
line see that see they both start the
same way they're talking about the same
integral right they're talking about
this into
but depending on where you are if you're
negative or if you're positive you get
two different answers you get sometimes
lot of x plus a constant where do you
get that again when X is positive but if
you're somewhere else if you are to the
left of the y axis you will get this guy
now look at that carefully right stare
really hard at it and forget the fact
that this logs here and plus C's here x-
x for positive fur- i have some language
to describe this to take me two things
and pour them into one it's the absolute
value of x that's where it comes from
see that over here behaviors like this
over here it behaves like that it's
doing two different things that's why
not just because I magically want
positive numbers it's because there are
two completely different functions the
coalescence of the same derivative so
when you go backwards you've got to know
where you are to know which anti-itch
primitive you should go to because we
get different ones in different sports
okay so remember what I said at the
beginning that is a two unit or three
and student you don't need to worry
about this okay if you wrote this
whatever I've done enough that's that's
it all right that's fine you're more
than often more than likely you're going
to get some boundaries here they'll be
positive and see just evaluate this at
the positives right no problems okay
extension to students are expected to do
that right off the bat okay
not really it's just that we expect
essential chooses to get a bit more of
the details for hotel but I hope you see
as I explained that like everything I
just established like there's no complex
numbers in there is no you don't know if
they are you with no context there's no
weird stuff like that it's all stuff
that has 23 inch students we know you
make a statement about differentiation
and the state about integration comes
with it and definitely to unit students
we know about absolutely days right it's
just a nice neat summarized form of two
things into one